what a week we have coming up next week
monday incredible absolutely no new show
because it is the fourth of July we will
have a classic david pakman show episode
for you if you're outside the US some of
our viewers ours as about twenty percent
of our viewers are I am sorry there will
be no new show and you will not have a
holiday but it is a holiday here Louis
and we will be taking it in that is
something we can all be thankful for on
tuesday i will be interviewing sean
carroll Sean Carroll is a physicist and
he is one of the top researchers into
the universe the theory of the expansion
of the universe what it means what does
the universe mean is there meaning is
their purpose etc sean carroll on
tuesday i'm looking forward to it on
Wednesday we will be speaking to Elbert
Guillory who is the a louisiana state
senator he switched to being a
Republican and as you can imagine when a
black elected official switches from the
Democratic craddock party to the
Republican Party and it is an election
year you can be sure he's going to be
giving speeches including at the
Republican convention so we're going to
talk to him on Wednesday and I'm looking
forward to that and then on Thursday the
great luke vargas will be joining me
from brazil where he is researching both
Zika the Zika virus as well as the total
fiasco around the upcoming olympic games
in brazil he's going to join us directly
from brazil internet connection
permitting and that will be great and
then friday we are going to revisit a
truly classic interview that I did with
l ron Hubbard's great-grandson l ron
hubbard of course the UH I i call it the
inventor or creator right of scientology
uh based it in some ways on stories
indistinguishable from his science
fiction writing we will speak to l ron
Hubbard's great-grandson jaime de wolf
or we will review that interview that I
did with jaime de wolf some time ago and
III it is one of my favorite interviews
fascinating guy the stories he tells
about the behind the scenes with his
great-grandfather truly true
incredible huge week next week if you
have any questions for all of the guests
i will be interviewing send them in
david at david pakman.com and if you
have guests suggestions for the people
you would like us to interview in the
future send those in david at david
pakman.com